all international travelers would need
to provide a negative covid19 test
result before
they'll be allowed to enter england or
scotland it comes amid continuing
concerns
about the distribution of curvid
vaccines let's speak to the transport
secretary now grant
shaps good morning to you minister um
before we uh
launch into that topic of the the
testing i just wanted to get your view
on whether you think
president trump should go in light of
the news this morning that there has
been a fifth death
uh from the capital from the storming of
the capital
i thought what happened completely
dishonors democracy and
uh you know it's just despicable to to
see those people encouraged to
go to the capitol building and so based
ransack it like that and as you said
they've been
people's lives that have been uh lost as
well um
so you know leave it to the americans to
resolve but
uh i mean you know america's great
democracy they've got all the
institutions uh in place and the the
checks and balances are there
to see something like that happen in the
united states was really quite
extraordinary
and i know there'd be quite some
reflection on that
but what's your view do you think the
25th amendment should be invoked
well it's not for me to sort of
interfere in american politics any more
than i expect an american president
or politician to do in in the uk but i i
you know everyone saw those scenes from
film you just ran as well uh and uh it
is inescapable that people were
encouraged to go
a march on the uh capitol building as
well and
the scene's really quite despicable um
but we'll leave it to the to the
americans i'm sure they'll
they'll uh they'll put the correct
whatever they feel the correct processes
in place
even regarding the the special
relationship and now our closest
ally you don't think it's our place to
comment
yeah i mean i think a lot lots always
said about the special relationship
um which is about the the office of the
president and about the the head of
state and america itself rather than
individuals
and i think it's very important to sort
of separate the two out but i don't i
don't i
in the same way as i wouldn't expect
americans to tell us for example
how we should handle you know anything
from
you know the brexit process we went
through to to anything else
in our own um politics i i wouldn't
expect to
tell the americans how to run things
that's that's their call but
everyone could see the scenes on tv
utterly condemn them i thought it was
despicable i thought it dishonored
a great democracy as well and uh and you
know
i think we can very fairly leave it to
the americans to work out what they
should do next that's
that's their call clearly okay let's
move on to uh
testing as regards england and scotland
for people
arriving into the country lay out to us
exactly what the new rules will be
well very simply uh if you're coming
here from anywhere
um whether you're a brits or whether
you're a foreign national
then you will need to take a covet test
up to 72 hours
before you come here um i should say
immediately it doesn't actually change
the other things that you'll need to do
in other words the quarantine
if you're coming from somewhere which
isn't on the travel corridor um
it remains in place so you'll still need
to do those things as well
but this is an extra uh check and we're
doing this now
because there are these variants that
were very very keen to keep
out of the country like the south
african variant
for example i was just going to ask why
exactly are you bringing this in now
when the travel industry have been
calling for this
for months they wanted something like
this put in place to alleviate the
pressure that they're under
well i want to be clear about what this
is and it isn't um it clearly
it's sensible because there's a new
version of the variant out there the
south african variant we saw the mink
one
uh the other week um and there are
concerns with the south african one in
particular about how effective the
vaccine would be
against it so we simply cannot take
chances
but in terms of response to
uh the coronavirus uh the the only
really surefire way is to make sure that
people quarantine or self
isolate and of course we've had that in
place for months and months since last
um
june um so today because of that variant
it's become much more urgent
we're not the only ones i just saw uh
this morning justin trudeau the the
canadian prime minister has actually
introduced exactly the same thing today
for the first time uh testing before
arrival
but as i say in our case and actually in
canada's case
it doesn't remove the need to quarantine
as well i'm afraid
but lots of other countries have had
strict entry requirements uh when it
comes to cove
testing before now why have we left it
so
late the simple answer is that actually
when you say it's a strict requirement
it's nowhere near as strict
as requiring self-isolation or
quarantine which will have a
far better chance at nearly 100 chance
when it's done properly
uh to ensure that the the covariate
virus isn't spread from somebody
who's infectious the difficulty that
we've always had with testing and that
difficulty remains i don't make any
bones about it is um if you test
somebody
but they're asymptomatic and somebody
who's about to fly for example
um would have to have been asymptomatic
otherwise they shouldn't have been
flying in the first place
um then they can still be carrying the
virus so you have a test on
whichever day up to three days before it
doesn't show that somebody definitely
doesn't have the virus it's just another
layer
another test and you ask why now as i
mentioned the south african vira uh
variation mutation of corona virus is
one reason
the other is that we've had to to wait
for the sector for the industry globally
to be able to provide enough coronavirus
tests and to be able to do so to the
right kind of standard
so it's a bit technical but we're not
asking for the pcr test which you often
hear about
what instead we're asking for a test of
a particular sensitivity and what's
called specificity
so up to a certain standard in other
words and
those can be pcr tests or what are
called lateral flow tests or
lamp tests uh the point is there are
just enough of those around now
to make this a workable approach to
having one extra check an extra layer
of security but as i say not the be-all
and end-all
so by your logic to add an even further
extra layer of
uh security why not test at the airport
well so if you're testing before
somebody comes here
and then you're testing remember uh
either five days later if people
are using what's called the test to
release scheme so you have to then
quarantine and test
or indeed having to carry out the full
quarantine that's ten days
um then that's giving us absolute
certainty uh about
it because uh the one the the sort of
gold standard really is quarantine or
self-isolation there's not
no tests can beat uh what that does um
so this gives you sort of
if you like the best of both worlds you
take a test up front you hope you're
going to catch some people
who are asymptomatic they don't know
they've got it but it turns out that
they have when they take that test and
therefore
they can't fly and don't fly but it's
really
the quarantine the self-isolation that's
the bit that really deals with
so are you categorically ruling out are
you categorically ruling out testing
at airports because what we're hearing
from the airports is that the units are
ready and waiting to go and to be
deployed
but they simply don't have the agreement
from government
no that's not right actually i was
speaking to the boss of heathrow last
night testing at airports been going on
for months at heathrow
it's used all the time when you fly to
countries italy
spain france you know you require
testing and often people will do that at
the airport though i should
abso absolutely stress people shouldn't
be flying anywhere at the moment we're
in a
lockdown situation of course with only
very few exceptions
but people coming here will often take
that test which can be up to 72 hours
before
they'll often do that at the airport in
rome or wherever they happen to be at
the time
uh before they fly here so testing in
airports is already a thing
it's just that sometimes people have
talked about testing in airports as if
it was some sort of
silver bullet solution the point i'm
trying to make is it isn't
unfortunately it doesn't actually detect
the majority of asymptomatic cases the
thing which does sort that out
is isolational quarantine that's the
thing which is still
the gold standard and it's still i'm
afraid going to be part of the the
solution here
how will you enforce people test before
traveling and have a negative test
before they actually
travel will that be left up to the
airline yeah the carriers
which could be an airline it could be a
course it could be the train or it could
be a ferry
uh will be required by law to check just
in the same way as they check you have a
passport or
if you're going to say the state's a
visa or a visa waiver they'll need to
check
whether you have a coronavirus test
valid
uh within 72 hours before you fly and
they're also
already having to check for what's
called the passenger locator form that's
the thing which enables us
to be able to contact somebody if we
then later find that they've been in
contact with someone
who has coronavirus so for the time
being i'm afraid these passenger locator
forms
and this coronavirus test are realities
of
of travel but uh good news as we know
from the prime minister's press
conference last night we already have
one and a half million of the most
vulnerable people
in the uk uh vaccinated more than the
whole of the rest of europe
and put together in fact and that number
is going to be increasing very very
quickly with a thousand
gp led vaccination stations um by
by uh next week so um we very much want
to get to a point where
we don't have to have any of these
things where where people are in fact
vaccinated and we can
return to life as normal so that that's
where we want to go this is not
something we want to do permanently
but for the time being we must keep
people safe and now scotland has
confirmed it will follow the plan
um but wells in northern ireland haven't
done so as yet
that leaves a gap in the defense doesn't
it because somebody could
fly into uh wales or travel by train
into wales
and then drive to to england
well i don't want to overspeak for wales
or northern ireland they have their own
administrations but
um i'm pretty certain they'll end up
actually being part of this
i spoke to them yesterday and they're
certainly indicating that
they want to be a part of it so i
suspect it will be a uk-wide
requirement from at some point next week
previously we relied just on
quarantining as you suggested for people
coming into the country
would it be fair to say that our borders
up until
now have been unsafe no absolutely not
and here's the proof by the way a lot of
people said to me
why don't you just shut the borders
close it entirely i'm putting aside the
fact that we're
you know an island and we require uh
people and goods and things in order to
be able to sort of function at all bring
in the medicine bring in the ppe but
putting
all of that aside look what happens in
the united states for example where they
did
last march entirely closed the border
so brits haven't been able to fly to
america since last march no one in
europe
it hasn't helped them at all not one
iota
and that is because as i confirmed with
the chief medical officer i asked him
about this right at the beginning
should we close the borders he said
there is no point in doing so you will
delay the whole thing by four or five
days
you'll stop the flow of goods and
medicines important
uh transactions taking place and you
won't stop the
virus once it's already here what we're
doing though with the
ability now with the mass testing that's
now available
and the ability to get asked people to
be tested is to try to prevent a new
variant
from entering the country we've done it
as i mentioned before
canada i see i've done it overnight as
well it's just a slightly load i'm going
to try to
going to have to interrupt you there we
have run out of time sadly thank you
very much for speaking to us this
morning